it's time to open the party  Wonderland is now open I like it when  the ideas come from you know facts that  I'm talking about operation love you  loose is it go  honey if you see my cell phone where did  your model go I don't play that anymore  get back here  seriously  [Music]  welcome to the mark have a nice day how  is this possible hello my name is steep  I know who you are you know who we are  my mom and I invented this place and  somehow you came to life  we're alive what happened here  the darkness happened it brought an army  of chimpanzees but sorry naughty it's  time to bring the park back to light  who's with me Oh with you oh no he's  allergic to voluntary  [Music]  such a woman those come-hither tusks Oh  [Music]  well that didn't work out at least we  got dinner  [Music]